over here we have Travis Scott wearing
something crazy this is a 5719 this is
done in white gold as I said before
Paddock Philipe they're setting diamonds
they're using the best quality the
highest quality and for a rapper of this
caliber he wants a factory so for here
he's rocking that on stage it's a
superstar piece this one will run you
around
$750,000 it's a crazy bezel and I love
the contrast between the round cut
diamonds and the baguette Cuts in the
center like you get such different shine
different pop from every area it's like
they did an incredible job with this one
it's a light show it's a light so I've
seen this one in person I was going to
pull out my credit card and keep it for
myself but it's going to run me too much
but the way that this thing shines
you're going to need sunglasses it's
crazy